do you believe any other Republican if
they were to become president would be
treated more fairly than Donald Trump
does anyone actually believe that you
believe it they're gonna pull it back
anyone out there who thinks that this is
a Donald Trump problem is completely
delusional all right let's see starting
off pretty well
not very happy I'm happy with that thank
you the Academy for this honor of honors
they told me I only have 45 seconds up
here which is 45 seconds more than the
Senate gave john bolton this week I'm
thinking maybe 20 doesn't move you about
it in the end the adults do the right
thing all of the goodwill in this Tommy
sit down shut up sit down from anyone in
Hollywood about john bolton before this
last word right yeah anyone bring up a
quote from any of these people on mit
romney before Larry what are you really
clear about this people and by the way
we don't know if this will be removed
you can go watch the blaze calm / mug
club
Mitt Romney Bolton I know right now you
think these people are your friends you
want to get with a cool club like David
French with a David French or French
tour David French Billy Crystal Rick
Wilson they're not your friends
let me ask you this question do you
genuinely think that these people or the
Democrats because I want on the same
must be honest they all hang out the
same dinners the multimedia
entertainment industrial complex is one
in the same as a Democratic Party does
anyone actually believe that let's say
Donald Trump were impeached in the
Senate did it and Mike Pence became
president or if let's just remove Mike
Pence from the equation do you believe
that any other Republican if they were
to become president would be treated
more fairly than Donald Trump does
anyone actually believe that you believe
it they're gonna pull it back they did
the same thing with george w bush that
he was a Nazi they did the same thing
when Mitt Romney was running binders
full of women that
he had his dog kennel on top of the car
Bush I will grant kind of weird I don't
know maybe it's Mormon thing I'm not one
to judge their culture but now these
people act like well it's time to be
Americans and find common ground you're
finding common ground with people who
will abandon you discard you and paint
you out to be the same evil not see that
they do Donald Trump appeasing
crocodiles is futile I don't know why
these people don't get it anyone you
need to understand this isn't about
Donald Trump right now no this is about
any other Republican yep from 2020
thereafter they set the precedent now
this is the first time an impeachment
like this has gone on for admitted non
impeachable crime right there was no way
I just am amazed that people neither uh
john bolton listen I disagree with him
but he was an American Hero Jon Coulton
hey listen I disagree with Mitt Romney
on policy but he's a decent man really
yes since when since when did you do
that in the election because I remember
you calling him a Nazi I remember with
Rick Santorum by the way who or whether
you agree with him or not you would have
to admit probably the most respectable
family man if you look into his ass with
scandal and instead you decided to
absolutely destroy tar and feather his
reputation his name anyone out there who
thinks that this is a Donald Trump
problem is completely delusional and I
say this by the way as someone I always
make sure to stress not because I want
to cover my own ass that I was not a
trump supporter in the primaries neither
why because I want you to know that I
was more wrong about that than anything
in my life in the sense that I didn't
think he was going to win I said there
was no way he was going to win Michigan
I was wrong so wrong I want to be clear
about that I admit it I apologize for it
and right now people think that Donald
Trump is a lightning rod no the
Democrats losing is the lightning rod
they're not after Barack Obama that the
tides returned the pendulum and shifted
remember they were talking about no
Republican would ever be president again
because the politics had shifted and
Barack Obama had shaken up the math the
this is a baby right now being put to
sleep in its crib who is just he's in
his throes of no I don't want to take a
nap and it's acting like a spoiled brat
it has nothing to do with the fact that
President Donald Trump is the one
putting them in their crib okay let me
ask you this would you be pushing for
john bolton to get airtime if it were
anything
other than teaching Donald Rowland by
the way ever impeaching Mike Pence yeah
well yeah exactly right after Donald
Trump but here's the thing anybody can
say something in a book anybody can say
something in a book are you telling me
they need to be able to go and testify
at any level of government to be able to
go and testify and say we had da one
Chelsea Handler at the hearing yes no I
come back around just good it's one
thing if we could just stop saying that
Mitt Romney was a man of principle
because at least politically he has
never been a man of prints no he hasn't
he was the author of Obamacare which
some people phrase because they're like
well he did it on a state level and I
understand that but still on a state
level he actually was not conservative
and really anyway she performed and I
understand when he became pro-life
here's the thing that doesn't make sense
to me because he was always a Mormon and
the position of the Mormon Church has
always been pro-life right Mormons are
typically pro-life so it's not like he
could say well I had a moment of faith
right and this was my aha moment his
flash of genius Mitt Romney just was
like wow I was a Mormon my whole life
and I was principled and I was a
Christian conservative but I was
pro-abortion and now I'm not because
it's Tuesday
I was running office he was a
Massachusetts Mormon yes district
changed why are you I took a poll it is
just remarkable to me someone on this
stage right now is going to act as
though they are supporter of John Bolton
rent or a Mitt Romney it is so unreal to
me or that when I bet you they'll all
claim that tonight wasn't political that
they don't see those littles when they
decide to go up and take jabs at Donald
Trump and it really at half of the
voting population because they're just
right hey if you enjoyed this video
subscribe or hit the notification bell
and click all notifications so that you
can be notified when new videos are pi
think there are videos playing in a box
net I don't care about that I can hear
the ocean
in this mug like like like I'm listening
to a two o'clock konk konk
conch is it conch or conch conch conch I
don't know but they really messed up
Peggy